la robotique arrive chez La Poste et si
avec des robots qui vont servir au tri
vous connaissez tous Colissimo avec
derrière des opérateurs qui vont dire
crier à la main et il y a un moment
cette tâche elle est relativement
fastidieuse la Poste a donc une idée ils
sont dit pourquoi est-ce qu'on prendrait
pas des robots qui vont venir faire ses
opérations à la place alors pour autant
on regarde un opérateur l'opérateur
qu'est-ce qu'il fait et bien il va venir
scanner ici son code il va venir scanner
le robot et l'emplacement du robot il va
lui poser un pli ici et lui le robot
sera exactement dans quel endroit il a
emmené le pli et comme ça il va faire le
tri directement il a mis dispatcher de
façon complètement intelligente l'idée
c'est pas de se dire les robots on ira
remplacer le boulot des humains hop là
pour ça parte rapidement mais l'idée
c'est plutôt de se dire comment soulager
des tâches qui sont compliquées des
tâches qui sont fastidieuses pour que
les robots et bien viennent les faire
directement et puis une deuxième point
qui est relativement intéressant c'est
que ça évite les erreurs c'est
l'innovation de la poste ça commence à
se déployer ben je trouve ça chouette de
pouvoir le voir ici fonctionner même si
c'est qu'une démo eh bien évidemment sur
le stand de La Poste à vivatech